would more testosterone guarantee that
you'll vote for the gop
a study from claremont graduate
university or kaju
found that increased levels of the main
male sex hormone can cause democrats to
become more conservative in their
political affiliation
during the 2012 election cycle
researchers analyzed 136
voting age men
lucky researchers am i right tyrus no
not right
they found a red shift
among guys who were giving testosterone
boosters compared to those who took
placebos or plaque bows
no wonder barry bonds wanted to join
cpac
anyway quote when weekly affiliated
democrats received additional
testosterone the strength of their party
fell by 12 and they reported 45
warmer feelings towards republican
candidates for president
before the testosterone treatment we
found that weakly affiliated democrats
had 19 higher basal testosterone than
those who identified strongly with the
party i don't know what i just said but
it sounds important
the scientists conclude wow these
liberal men are a bunch of
it's true it's in the research i didn't
say that
so no wonder
elon's last name is musk
the tesla founder vowing to vote
republican tweeting in the past i voted
democrat because they were mostly the
kindness party but they become the party
of division and hate so i can no longer
support them and will vote republican
meanwhile the testosterone lobby is
alright already trying to cash in
are you sluggish during the day wished
you lived in another country do you have
strange thoughts like considering voting
democrat then maybe you should try
testosterone
from the dawn of time this hormone is
responsible for every awesome thing
mankind has ever done and now it's
helping a new generation of weekly
affiliated dems unleash their inner
conservative look i used to love bernie
sanders but ever since i started using
testosterone i can't stop thinking about
how smaller governments and less
regulations could really unlock the
potential of the private sector
damn right kid i spent every day of my
life reading about the green new deal
now i spend most of my time reading
about the constitution and best of all
no longer a virgin nice that's one of
the side effects so if you're ready to
quit leaning left and start loving free
speech police military small governments
in the old red white and blue then try
testosterone
well done acting
[Applause]
so dave much like this study you've also
followed 136 men
usually home
do you like greg i don't know why why
not
i haven't seen you in a year right it's
been a while it's gonna
cover you with abuse this makes sense no
well i had no idea that it had something
to do with testosterone that would take
a liberal and make a conservative i
thought it was just the soy that was
keeping them as liberals because they're
always drinking soy milk that's true but
isn't that that's why they got that's
where the whole soy boy came that's
where the soy boy came but i can tell
you as someone that was right i'm the
why i left the left guy someone that was
a progressive i was a liberal the whole
thing i can tell you i've never been
more virile than i am as i sit here at
this very moment as when i saw you
earlier in the mail room you were
telling me
i mean we weren't looking at our faces
when we were talking no
but
you know i could you know i could feel
your breath
how long are we going i told you
i told you this was going to be the
number one show in late night oh well
remember we are the most successful show
ever that says things that are
completely twisted and wrong okay uh
pirates i got i hate the corrector you
keep saying we yeah
yes that's true
do you buy this
no no you don't
i had
it's i get oh i get so
just mad because it can never be
because it's the right decision yes
because it makes sense
because we read and we think and we
don't like big taxes no we get gassed up
lift weights
and go vote
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god and you know what the other
side is going to do here don't you
they're going to say see the republicans
the conservatives they're all aggressive
with that testosterone and they are all
just mean and then there's going to be
this you know this anti-male thing yeah
as if there wasn't already but you know
they'll use it that way
this little study because it's only 136
and yeah one more thing i'm sorry how
dare you barry bonds never tested
positive for anything
never
once he only tested positive for my love
effort he tested with effort
she'd be in the whole thing
[Laughter]
cat you actually have more testosterone
than i do
what makes you say that
when i first met you i mean i i didn't
understand that what was coming out of
your mouth sounded like a truck driver
yeah but like you see me you don't like
necessarily expect this voice
uh yeah i i don't know i i should get i
probably do have a lot of testosterone
like the voice and like the personality
yes
but i i don't anything else other than
commenting on my hormones yes
yeah do you buy this
i i don't know i don't buy anything for
130 like 136 people like you said it is
a small number but
it could make sense you know because
hormones do affect you sometimes oh yeah
you know like anyone who's a chick will
be like duh
and i am a chick you are that's you
can't stress that enough
the doctors were confused for a while
why do i laugh like beavis and butthead
i love when people tell me on the
internet like stop laughing like that as
if this is the one i have chosen
it's true
all right we gotta go up go up coming up
we gotta go up
is canceling wokeness a bribe to keep
netflix viewers from hitting unsubscribe
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else